depuis le début de la pandémie
le travail de myrna aimons l'arrivée
c'est compliquer considérablement l
enquête sur les signalements et elle
doit entrer chez les gens pour constater
l'état des lieux est celui des enfants
certains parents lui ouvre la porte
d'autre part on avait souvent le
commentaire monsieur legault veut pas
qu'on sorte mais vous allez pas rentrer
monsieur legault dit qu'on doit rester à
la maison vous avez pas d'affaires à
venir contaminer mon milieu n'est pas
question que vous rentrez chez nous si
moi je peux pas sortir le retour à
l'école primaire du 11 mai les
travailleuses sociales de la dpj
l'attendait voir les enfants vulnérables
de près et leur parler librement
devenait crucial mais encore fallait-il
que les enfants se présentent en classe
ce qu'on comprend c'est que c'est pas
nécessairement non familles vulnérables
qui sont retournés à l'école on a
beaucoup de nos familles qui ont gardé
les enfants à la maison
moins de la moitié des enfants sous sa
responsabilité sont retournés à l'école
ses collègues font le même constat
même si presque aucun cas de co vide n'a
été recensé dans leur région de
plessisville
il a donc fallu trouver d'autres moyens
de garder l'oeil ouvert par le biais du
téléphone ou de l'ordinateur de
l'application facetime et on se promener
en fait vraiment facetime comme que les
gens en situation qu'au vu des fêtes
avec leurs familles le tour je
l'emmenais d'ouvrir les frigos et
montrer le frigo allait montrer la
chambre les enfers milly pajot est
responsable de 21 enfants de 5 ans et
moins et l avis de saisie les limites de
ces visites virtuelles
après deux semaines la vidéo et le
téléphone ne suffisait plus à calmer son
inquiétude au sujet d'une de ces
familles répondait plus au téléphone
ne voudrait plus non plus les messenger
fait qu avec l enfant est en mode 12
mois je trouvais qui est vraiment
préoccupant d'aller dans cette maison là
puis quand je suis arrivé le et j'ai vu
qu'ils aiment à fresnes le 19 mars un
arrêté ministériel sans précédent secoue
la dpj les enfants placés en famille ou
en centre d'accueil ne pourront plus
visité leurs parents biologiques pour
éviter les risques de propagation
si tout le monde a compris au départ ça
n'a pas duré
le terme inhumain gelé entendu souvent
quelqu'un inhumain la part des parents
qui trouvaient que tu es venu - il
devait peut-être un contact avec leurs
enfants pour des périodes plus prolongée
une absence douloureuse pour les enfants
également toutes les intervenantes l'on
remarqué mais ce qu'elles ont noté aussi
ce sont les effets bénéfiques de
l'interruption des visites parents
enfants moi je m'attendais que ça serait
très problématique
j'étais quand même étonné de voir que
les enfants sont plus apaisé donc nos
jeunes qui ont des difficultés
d'attachement des difficultés de
comportement importants on voit que ça
diminue les signalements aussi ont
diminué de moitié la liste d'attentes
frise le zéro et le tribunal de la
jeunesse reporte la plupart des dossiers
non urgents pendant quelques semaines
les intervenants de la dpj on tue ce
qu'elles n'ont jamais eu du temps pour
compléter leur dossier ça mais jamais
avant 12 ans je sais ça
c'est quand même assez particulier un
calme étrange qui elles le savent ne
durera pas ici pascal turbie et de radio
canada montréal